Or you've got to at least say something.
Emerald Technologies is the local source
for computer sales and services.
They carry Apple and Windows laptops
for every budget and custom-built desktop systems
for gaming, video editing, and office work.
They carry all kinds of cables, chargers, routers, printers,
and whatever other gizmos you might
need to get the job done.
Since 1998, Emerald Technologies has
worked to keep your computer alive and happy
and out of the e-waste pile.
Stop by their Garberville office just up the way from Ray's,
check out emeraldtech.biz, or give them a call 923-1268.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's 7-0-1.
This is Redwood Community Radio, KMUD,
Garberville, KMUD, Eureka, KLA, Laytonville,
where the views and opinions expressed
throughout the broadcast day are those of the speakers
and not necessarily those of the station, staff,
or underwriters.
Time is made available for all sorts of viewpoints.
And thank you all so much for choosing to listen to us.
Get ready for "Ask Your Herb Doctor."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And we have the doctors in the house.
I believe I do.
Andrew, are you there?
Do I got you, Andrew?
Hmm.
Well, I thought I had Dr. Murray.
I do have Dr. Peat here.
Dr. Peat, do I have you?
I'm still here.
OK.
And I had a technical error.
And I think--
I'll be back.
We're going to listen to the theme music first
for a second here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
We have one of the doctors.
And I got to get Dr. Peat back.
Dr. Herb Doctor?
engineer, are we on?
Yes, Dr. Murray, you are on.
OK, thank you.
Welcome to this month's "Ask Your Herb Doctor."
My name's Andrew Murray.
From 7 to 8 PM, we run these shows every Thursday, Friday
of the month.
"Ask Your Herb Doctor" is the name of the show.
And for the longest time now, we've
been joined by Dr. Raymond Peat, PhD,
who's been weighing in with his academic take
on a lot of different subjects that are sometimes
controversial and sometimes not, but always informative.
So once again, we're very pleased to have Dr. Peat
with us on the show.
Are you there, Dr. Peat?
I'm getting Dr. Peat back right now.
OK.
Yes, we have Dr. Peat on the line.
Hi, Dr. Peat.
Thanks so much for giving your time again this evening.
OK, I don't hear Dr. Peat.
I know this is a remote programming here.
And I've had a few problems in the past.
Dr. Peat can hear you.
Barely.
I can hear him.
I can barely hear him.
Can you try it out?
I did get that.
That was-- I could hear that.
Well, launch in.
And I think he can hear you too.
Yeah.
OK, all right, good.
Well, let's start once again.
And it's "Ask Your Herb Doctor,"
KMUD, Garberville 91.1 FM.
From now until 8 o'clock at the end of the show,
you're invited to call in with questions, hopefully related
to this month's subject of epigenetics
and some experimental cancer treatments
and also a little bit of COVID catch-up.
The number is 707-923-3911, sorry.
So that's, once again, 707-923-3911 from 730
until the end of the show date.
We're once again very pleased to have Dr. Layman Peat with us.
Dr. Peat, you with us?
Yes.
Good, OK.
Sorry about the technical difficulties.
For those people who perhaps have never heard you before
or would like to find out more about you,
we'll give out your details at the end of the show.
But would you please just give a round-up
of your academic professional background
so people can get an idea of where your work is coming from?
I was studying and teaching in the humanities
for about 10 years before I decided
to go to graduate school in biology, which
was in 1968 to 1972, University of Oregon,
where I got a PhD in reproductive physiology
and aging.
And my intention had been to study
nerve biology when I went to the university,
following up on ideas of how language and brain work.
But because of dogmatism in the nerve biology section,
I ended up with reproductive physiology
as a way to concentrate on interactions of hormones,
metabolism, and development. And over the next almost 50 years,
I've been continuing to study those areas.
And you've had quite a long history
of actually consulting with people.
And firsthand, I won't say experimental,
because it's not experimental, but first-hand guidance
with philosophies that you have formulated over time here.
And much of what I've understood from you in the last 10 years
has been related to energy production.
I think I would sum that up.
In the terms of creative energy production and stemming
the dissolution of energy, whether that is from a dietary
perspective or a supplemental perspective.
But tonight's show, again, it piqued my interest.
And I cannot claim to be a scientist or knowledgeable
in any way on the subject.
But I have some definite questions I'd like to ask you
and to also help to understand the subject a little more
simply for listeners who perhaps don't have too much
of a science background.
But a lot of what you can bring out in epigenetics
is very relevant in terms of understanding
the simple concepts of it.
So going to the term "epigenetics,"
it's basically-- I think I could sum it up by saying
it's a heritable phenotype, the change of which does not
involve alterations in the DNA sequence.
Now, before I let you take the floor with the concept
of epigenetics, and I start to question you,
this one people to understand the two differences
of phenotype and genotype.
When we're talking about genes and DNA
and what they code for and what they do,
the genotype gives the instruction.
And the phenotype in an organism is its appearance.
So I saw that an account-- and the word "environmental
enrichment," which I know you'll bring out in the context
of altering or rather adapting to the changes in epigenetics.
The epigenetics, themselves, may account
for a significant fraction of what
they term the missing heritability as DNA mutations
only explained a minority of the expected heritable fraction.
And they said that this discrepancy
is known as the missing heritability.
So when you describe epigenetics for our listeners, some of which
may not be as science-based, if you
could describe the basic outlines of epigenetics
and how, whether it's DNA changes in methylation
or the histones that the genes wrap around
or this non-coding RNA that get altered
and how the changes to those bring about profound changes
in genetic information and what gets turned on
and what gets turned off and how this epigenetic change really
alters the structure of our consciousness, I think,
in a lot of ways, or conversely, our consciousness
can alter the structure of our epigenetics.
So would you just describe what it
is that you understand as epigenetics
and how they play into our health?
The established powers in biology
have been very resistant to the idea
that there could be any transgenerational influence
of experience.
And that has involved even reducing and emptying
the idea of what happens during adaptation.
Why does exercise build stronger muscles
and what happens during learning and developing new ideas?
The very idea of change was resisted powerfully
by the people who saw the organism as a compilation
of specific traits once developed in infancy
or achieving maturity.
The idea was that our traits and our parts
were like a clock mechanism.
The parts operated, allowed the machine to work.
But nothing very deep was changing all
during the adult lifetime.
And that has an extensive ideological background
in which the organism was seen as nothing
but a compilation of parts, each of which
is eternal and unchangeable.
And the idea that the organism might be in some way
deeply changing after it has achieved maturity
puts in doubt the whole idea that the immortal genes
specify the traits that together make up
the machine of the organism.
The idea of the machine is intended
to eliminate the idea that the parts are constantly changing.
But in reality, when you look at the experience of yourself
or of other organisms, you see that every day there
is learning and change.
So you can't really do anything twice
because the second time you do it is you're a different person.
And this idea really has a great biological significance
that every moment of your experience,
you're in development all the way through your lifespan.
And the immune system is constantly
operating and recording your interactions
with antigenic material or possible allergens
or immunological stimulants the same way
axons and experiences change the way you interpret the world.
The structure of your brain is constantly changing.
And that interacts with your constantly changing immune
system.
And all the rest of your body is moment to moment
undergoing adaptation.
And it isn't just a technological thing.
The ideas that are constantly changing in your mind
are actually changing the properties of the brain
cells, your immune cells, and probably all of the cells.
No one has looked at every cell in the body,
but pretty much every cell in the body,
every functional cell is likely to have a fine, nervous fiber.
So the body isn't just chemically
communicating like a swarm of insects
attracted to the smell of honey or something,
but there is a very deep penetration of fine nerve
fibers into all of the tissues, integrating
the whole body and its chemistry with the conscious purpose
and ongoing behavior of the organism.
So any little event happening in your body
is also adding to the sum of development.
Technically, people are using epigenetics
just to mean certain chemical changes that persist
from the state of one cell after that cell divides.
But the persistence of a physiological state
from moment to moment is really the simplest and most basic idea
of epigenetics.
Every moment we inherit the whole past of our organism
and the fact that we don't change drastically
and unrecognizably is that there is a logic and a momentum
in these developmental changes that the whole system is
working in integration and with a rational set of goals.
The extreme way and analogy biologically
would be the transformation of a tadpole to a frog.
That involves epigenetic changes of a very drastic sort.
But it's good to keep that in mind as hidden outside
our immune system and nervous system
are having these constant little transformations
or metamorphoses.
So it's not as drastic as a tadpole turning into a frog.
But our immune system and brain in particular
are recognizably different over very short time spans.
And what you said a few moments ago caught my attention.
And I kind of tried to sum it up as you--
and again, this is not preaching or anything
to those who have never really thought about the subject.
But I think it's a very good point
in explaining adaptation and epigenetics
and how it affects us psychologically
in terms of what we believe.
It reminds me that you are what you believe yourself to be
and that the subject of positive reinforcement or affirmations,
positive affirmations, are seemingly a roadmap
to a better future.
Because that is a way, in many ways,
I think, of changing your perception, your outlook,
your mental state, and your physical state
therein by epigenetic changes that can occur purely
through positive reinforcement.
Positive or negative.
The environment, to a great extent,
is imposing unpleasant degenerative dangers on us.
And for example, if you put an animal in isolation,
social distancing, the animal becomes more inflamed.
The whole immune system is deranged
in the direction of inflammation just
by the depressing experience of being isolated from misfriends.
And if you reverse that, do the opposite,
and give them lots of fun social contacts and lots
of varied things to do, an enriched environment,
that suppresses, that ends the inflammatory processes
and starts the organism back on the constructive developmental
process away from the degenerative processes.
So in terms of going--
These ideas have been known to common people
for hundreds of years.
Lamarck, for example, said that if an organism needs
longer legs or stronger arms or whatever,
it will develop them by striving.
Basically, exercise improves the physiology and structure.
Anyone can see it happening.
As you change your life, your organism cooperates
and becomes more efficient in that way of life.
But the Darwinists didn't like that idea
of the intelligence of the common person
or the common organism.
And they invented the assumption of randomness.
It's a metaphysical idea created out of thin air
that, for some reason, changes can only be random.
And they did it to atoms that said
that the change of one type of atom to another
can only be random and unpredictable.
Nuclear transmutations are a chance event.
And they applied that to biological changes.
At first, the traits were immortal and unchanging then.
When they saw mutations or actual changes happening,
they said those are only completely random and useless.
And the mechanism of intelligent adaptation of learning
to play the flute or the trumpet or something,
you have to develop muscular skills, mental skills,
and change your organism to do that.
But that kind of adaptation, they
created a way to see it as simply a summing up
of many meaningless random diffusions of molecules
through the system.
You change your behavior.
And the modifications that happen as a result
of that changed behavior involve random diffusion
of particles that end up changing the genes.
But the whole idea of avoiding purposefulness
at every point of life processes that has been going on now
for about 200 years.
OK, you're listening to "Ask Europe" Dr. K.M.E.
Garberville 91.1 FM from 7.30 until the end of the show.
You're invited to call in the questions.
The number is 7079233911, Dr. Raymond P., our guest speaker.
Dr. P., you talked about moment-to-moment changes
and you've described the process by which epigenetics can affect
us, definitely negatively from an inflammatory point of view.
And you've also mentioned that stresses.
And you mentioned isolation, and I think in response to COVID
and the isolation that's been imposed upon the masses,
as well as authoritarianism, which
has been put on every continent of the planet
by pretty much every government and their people.
And deficiencies in freedom, deficiencies in social
engagement decreases in any kind of creative outlets,
whether it's yoga, exercise, meeting people for discussion
groups, et cetera, et cetera.
All of these things definitely could
be construed in the context of epigenetics
has been very negative for us in terms of,
whilst our DNA might not physically change,
the components of some of these genes
can definitely be switched off by epigenetic changes
that occur under these stresses.
And the things that are activated
by authoritarianism and isolation and so on
include an excess of serotonin production.
And that causes a rigid tendency to conformism that, at the same
time, is cooling the body, slowing metabolism,
making it more passive, leaning towards learned helplessness
just by the excess of stress-induced serotonin excess.
The serotonin, in turn, activates all
of the stress-related other hormones.
But its worst function is to slow the metabolism,
increase inflammation, tending towards a degeneration
of death, and estrogen is the other killing
stress-related chemical that lowers the body temperature,
predisposes it to more inflammation,
and makes it more receptive to authoritarianism,
and creates a failure of adaptiveness.
So all of this is a spiraling, a kind of a compounding factor,
one negative thing after another.
And it's in complete odds with a mindfulness mindset
or a positive mindset, because the environment--
well, it's not that the person's obviously got their mind set
on mindfulness, and they are not going
to be subjugated by all of the control,
for example, during this pandemic.
Obviously, there are people that will be mindful of their own
place in the universe, as it were,
and they're not going to allow this external stimulator to
suppress them, because they either
have a very strong mindset based on positive affirmation
and mindfulness or distrust of what's going on, obviously.
But these changes--
and just talk about a little bit about what
these epigenetic changes can do in terms
of their worst consequences, in terms of switching genes off
or switching them on, in terms of inflammation
and other carcinogenic effects.
The whole idea of epigenetics is flexibility and reversibility.
And so it's very antagonistic through all of the doctrines
that say cancer is incurable.
Advanced heart disease and kidney disease
are incurable, and so on.
The epigenetic idea explains how they develop
from bad environmental opportunities
and also potentially shows routes by which they
can be reversed.
It's a very optimistic view in relation
to health and development.
And where the genetic view says you can only develop so far,
if your genes are bad, you're going
to be a sickly, unproductive person.
The epigenetic approach says the genes are only
a very sketchy determinant.
Many other things determine our vitality.
For example, the exposure prenatally
to too much estrogen lowers the body temperature,
reduces the growth of the brain, and predisposes
to inflammatory diseases, obesity,
and lifelong weakness.
The exposure to extra glucose simply
added in glucose to the developing gestating animal
or the hormones, such as progesterone,
that provide a more reliable amount of glucose,
increase the growth of the brain, the thickness of the cortex,
the energy level, metabolic rate, and longevity.
The bigger the brain is able to develop
by these good circumstances, the longer the organism tends
to live.
Very interesting.
Again, for people that are listening,
I would encourage you to go online.
And whilst it's not a definitively accurate,
maybe, source of information, PubMed certainly
have plenty of articles attesting
to the science of epigenetics and attesting to the very thing
that Dr. Pink's mentioning in terms
of environmental enrichment as being positively favorable
in the outcomes of various animal models for disease
resistance and/or recovery.
So whilst it may-- and not to me, perhaps,
but maybe some people who are listening
have just caught the show.
As I've said, you really are not just what you eat,
but you can become what you believe yourself
to be in terms of positive affirmation and reinforcement,
and that your thoughts really are far more powerful than people
understand in terms of affecting their outcome,
their physiology, and changing their manifestations of disease
in their body or not.
And that, as Dr. Piezel mentioned,
that it's a reversible situation, the genome,
that makes up who we are physically on the outside,
that people see, as well as inside, chemically,
what people don't see and how we interact with things.
It's very plastic.
It's very fluid.
And it's very dynamic.
It's not at all fixed, as Dr. Peat said,
that science, especially genetics,
probably from the moment it was dreamt of,
was a tool by which to describe things inherently at that.
But the genome itself is very, very flexible.
And it's not a very specific determinant of your outcome,
because epigenetics do play a big role in it.
And actually, this whole missing heritability
is explained by epigenetics.
And it's something that people should really take a look at.
It's a pretty novel science.
And it is a very worthy science, for science's sake.
Might sound a little nebulous to some people
listening that you can change the way you
are by thinking differently.
But this type of change can be described
as an epigenetic change over time.
And the very concepts of authoritarianism and isolation
and going without and deficiency and lack, all of this
breeds an inflammatory, stressed state,
which his only outcome generally is negative and energy
decreasing.
So certainly, changing your mindset
is a good way of getting some kind of restitution from this.
And then obviously, the chemical changes that happen.
Dr. Peat, you've mentioned things like estrogen and serotonin.
And these have certainly, unfortunately,
been labeled as positive things in the medical field.
But we're very mindful of the fact
that these are very pro-inflammatory.
In terms of epigenetics, I wanted
to bring out, just for people to understand or just highlight
it in a fairly simplistic manner, that--
and I wasn't aware of this until I started looking.
And I had, actually, when I was studying herbal medicine,
the two principles were both Dutch
who'd gone through the Second World War
and had endured the famine of 1944 to 1945,
which they called the Dutch hunger winter famine.
And I remember one of the professor
who was describing the torture, if you like,
because they were in such famine,
because the Germans had cut off the food supply,
that there was a time when the only thing that you could eat
was daffodil bulbs.
And they've done studies now on children
from women who went through that.
And these studies have shown a pretty clear link
to certain genes being switched off
and that these people are certainly
more prevalent in manifesting heart disease,
schizophrenia, and type 2 diabetes.
And they're saying that they can link it fairly positively
to the epigenetic changes that occurred
as a result of this famine.
What about that, Dr. Peabody?
We have a caller, too, after that.
OK.
In recent--
Let's go ahead and take this first caller.
Sorry, Dr. Peabody.
Let's take this first caller.
Then I'll ask your feedback on that Dutch hunger famine.
So caller, you're on the air.
Where are you from and what's your question?
Sorry, to interrupt, you have a great dialogue
going on a very important topic.
But I have two separate questions.
One relates to the product turpentine
or the ethers related to it.
Back in, I think, 1899, if you looked at a medical textbook,
I think there were like 45 different problems or illnesses
that allegedly, at the time, were supposedly cured,
or at least improved, by ingesting turpentine.
Now, when you look at any turpentine,
or the mindset is, oh, it's poison.
And perhaps there's some that's poison.
But I just wanted to get a sense, clearly,
that the pharmaceutical companies are not
going to want you to be doing this.
But back in 1899, do you believe that they were right?
Forget about what's going on currently.
Currently, there is still research
going on showing the turpentine family.
Each type of conifer has its own variant of turpentine.
But some of these are very, for example,
stimulate wound healing, accelerate healing
under anti-inflammatory.
And others are antibiotic, very important biological beneficial
effects.
And I don't know where this culture of fearing turpentine
came from, but it happened to coincide
with the disappearance of cheap turpentine as paint thinner.
I used to very often use turpentine
as my solvent for painting, but where
it used to cost a couple of dollars a gallon.
It's now up around $30 or $40 a gallon and almost impossible
to get.
It's funny you say that because I think I've called earlier
and I had a problem with my shoulder.
I tore my rotator cuff.
I opted not to get surgery.
But there is a variant of turpentine
that I did on an empty stomach take, not a lot, but enough
and literally within minutes.
I'm talking minutes, the pain would disappear.
I mean, almost exactly what you're saying.
And so I don't know whether it sort of--
I don't know that it kills parasites or bad creatures
in your body, which are maybe more likely to go
to the wound site.
But it certainly numbs them or reduces inflammation,
as you said, in some fashion.
To me, it's clearly-- everything you said has clearly
been-- I've already proven it.
I just wanted to get your view.
The other question relates to something I'd asked before on
thyroid.
There's a lot of people who believe, and certainly I
believe, that thyroid is so important and learned about it
from you.
But I'm not really one who feels that I would want to be
reliant on any sort of thyroid mechanism--
or medicine, excuse me.
So the other approach that Broda Barnes mentions and others
mention is to actually take iodine.
And I know I've heard some of your answers on that.
Maybe you'll have a different view on the context of the way
I'm going to ask this.
But in the current environment we're in, you've got reds,
you've got all these other halogens that compete and
block iodine.
So it seems to me it's harder--
well, I shouldn't say it this way.
Is it reasonable, without taking kelp with all the--
just to take straight iodine, perhaps, from the earth, and
essentially a bioavailable amount, a very small amount,
that ultimately might be enough to help your thyroid do what
it's supposed to do without having to compete with these
other-- or maybe to get around, circumvent the use of
these haloids that your thyroid doesn't want to use?
In the last 20 years or so there have been several dozen
studies showing that thyroid disease corresponds to the
introduction of iodized salt.
I think that's a bad product.
So the other thing is, as you'll agree, and I don't
want to say we're sure picking studies here that people
say, well, aspirin causes burns a hole in your stomach.
Well, yeah, sure, if you take a whole bottle.
But they don't tell you they put a whole bottle in the
test, but they want to do the research so you buy their
other products.
So the same could be true of iodine, frankly.
But I don't disagree.
So if you took the colored iodine or the iodized salt,
yeah, there's all kinds of other toxins.
But if you get a pure form of bioavailable iodine in a very
small amount, where there's nothing else, it seems like a
reasonable thing to do.
Tell me why I'm--
Yeah, but over one milligram a day, I think is risky.
Yeah, exactly.
I was thinking like 600 micrograms, 500 to 600, one
drop, literally.
Anyway, I was going to test it.
I'll let you know how it goes.
But you don't think--
that's not crazy.
The things you're talking about I agree with.
You can't trust any research since you were in school,
right?
They're all lying.
Look at COVID.
I mean, look at this.
It's not-- they can't even isolate it.
So I think you do have to do it yourself and test it in a
reasonable manner.
So anyway, I'm going to give that a shot, unless you think--
so you're saying if you use 500 milligrams and it's close to
pure iodine and doesn't have other toxins, it's probably not
a bad thing to test, right?
It's not going to be safe.
Sorry.
And I think turpentine is something that really needs
lots of fresh research now, in terms of what we know about
the communication of cells and cytokines and the process of
inflammation and endo-inflammation.
Whoops.
Sorry, I dropped him.
We got another caller, though.
Yeah, OK.
Well, thank you for your call, caller.
Let's get another call in.
Caller, where are you from?
What's your question?
From Southern Hovoldt.
And my question is this, is I don't know what really iodine
and turpentine have to do with the topic, which is
epigenetics, as far as I could tell.
And I heard the guest in very general terms how
epigenetics works, but I'm wondering if we could get a
little more specific about how that really works and if the
guest could talk about the mechanism for affecting and
turning on and off the DNA, which is my understanding of
epigenetics works, having to do with DNA methylation and
histamine modification and those mechanisms.
So could the guest actually talk in more specific terms
about how epigenetics works biochemically and about the
limitations of what you can actually do with
epigenetics?
Because it's not like I heard the host say that you can do
anything and be anything and that sort of thing.
My understanding of epigenetics is it's very limited in how it
can really affect the biochemistry in that it does
not change the DNA.
It just modifies whether that DNA is turned on in particular
cells or not turned on.
So the actual amount of documented evidence that
epigenetics can really change our lives as human beings is
pretty limited.
And it doesn't mean that our experiences, like being under
a lot of stress or not getting enough to eat or those kinds of
real stressors in human beings, can't affect us.
And that's what epigenetics is studying.
But the idea that we can do anything with epigenetics is
just a misuse, in my opinion, of what's out there actually in
the science.
So could the guest talk a little bit more about the DNA
methylation and the actual mechanisms for which
epigenetics can change the -- whether our DNA gets activated
or not in certain cells?
Thank you.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you.
Dr. P., did you get the grasp of that question?
The attachment of methyl groups to DNA has got the most
interest and credibility among the standard genetics workers.
And in principle, with stress and aging, we lose the ability
to activate genes.
And so the general idea is that our DNA becomes too
methylated, turning off massive amounts of genes so that we're
very slow to renew our cell proteins.
But certain islands of DNA become under-methylated as a result of
hormone imbalances and stress and so on.
And if you have a tumor repressor which becomes
methylated, you stop repressing tumors.
And if you have under-methylation of something which is
considered an oncogene, you can activate oncogenes by losing
the inhibiting methylation.
And so the connection of DNA methylation to stress and cancer
development and aging is getting a huge amount of research.
But there are the second most popular mechanism of epigenetics
for the conventional crowd is changes in the histones, which
are -- they are able to block activation of massive amounts
of DNA.
And acetylation, there is methylation of histones and also
attachment of acetyl groups.
And when acetyl is attached, it lets the DNA become active.
And so deacetylators become DNA gene-suppressive.
And there's a lot of research on that too.
And now the microRNA regulatory systems has tremendously
complicated the area.
But the idea of the unexpressed 97% or 98% of our DNA, which
doesn't make genes, this is clearly involved in regulatory
processes that are not genetic in the ordinary sense, but
obviously contribute to the epigenetic momentum that the
organism has and people are suggesting that a failure of that
is involved in the old age and the increased susceptibility to
viruses and degeneration.
And there are probably others, but the whole idea of the
mechanism of how these changes of function and structure without
changing the actual gene composition, the whole repertoire
that the organism uses is just now really being suspected.
And I think the emphasis on DNA methylation has been taken out
of proportion.
Estrogen and progesterone are both major regulators of gene
methylation and demethylation and histone acetylation and
deacetylation.
So the hormones and the systems energy largely regulated by
thyroid hormone and the balance between carbon dioxide and
lactate.
Carbon dioxide being the quieting, the efficiency
promoting anti-inflammatory substance, lactate being the
excitatory inflammation promoting de-energizing
substance going with a low metabolic efficiency.
Okay, well your listeners are going to come in with the
guide for 91.1 FM from now to the end of the show if people
want to call in, we can get a couple of one or two quick
questions in, the number 70798, sorry, 923 3911, I'll say that
once again, 707 923 3911, guest speaker, Dr. Raymond PeaT.
I had actually just told the caller who was on that, he
probably was, well I told him he had to get it out in 30
seconds and he actually just hung up.
So you have like four minutes to clean up and we have an
underwriter to thank at the end, so that's super awesome.
Okay, so we're probably getting too close to the top of the
aisle to take any more calls then.
Okay, all right, well, Dr. PeaT, you're saying basically
then to sum up, there's an energy situation when the
organism is fully energized and there's plenty of CO2 and
there is an active thyroid and metabolism is working the way
it should be, there is much less chance of any epigenetic
changes taking place that would destabilize the system.
Yeah, energy is the thing that protects and guides the
proper expansion of our structures.
The energy increase under the influence of thyroid and
oxidative metabolism and carbon dioxide, this is a constant
ongoing flow, which is tending constantly to complexify our
structure, building structure constantly, if your energy
fails then it goes the other way, structure de-complexifies
and deteriorates.
Okay, well, I probably should stop you there.
Thank you so much for giving your time again.
Dr. Peat, I'll sign off for giving information about how
people can reach you after this moment.
Okay, very good, thanks.
Thank you.
Okay, so the people who've tuned in this evening, Dr.
Raymond Peat, www.raypeat.com, he's got a fully referenced
library, if you will, of papers, newsletters that he's
written, backed up and fully referenced.
Epigenetics, another one of those subjects that he's weighed
in on again and, yeah, he has a living testimony to further
knowledge outside of science for science's sake because he's
looking not for the money, but he's looking for the truth, and
so plenty of information on his website.
I really wanted to get to, you know, very quickly just say a
little bit about this, I really wanted to get to talk about
Dr. Nicholas Gonzalez, who was a medical doctor, died in 2015,
but had a pretty successful practice treating pancreas
cancer, pancreatic cancer patients who were rapidly
progressive, this very aggressive disease, rapidly
fatal, but his speech, there's plenty of audios online, where
you can hear him, in particular one was titled "Why Clinical
Trials Where Cancer Cures a Futile," again, somebody else in
the medical field who really wanted to be altruistic and
actually help people with cancer, came up with a
protocol that was definitely treating people, but was
absolutely dogged along the way at every set by the National
Institutes of Health and various other organisations who did not
want him to be successful in doing this, and so there are
always alternatives out there, the internet's a great source
for information, but watch out for misleading information
because that's also very relevant to the search.
And so, maybe next month we'll get into Dr. Nicholas Gonzalez
if we don't wrap up the epigenetics part of it, so our
website is westernbotanicalmedicine.com, and we can be
reached Monday through Friday, we have an 800 number, 1-888-WBM
herb, if you like, my email address is andrew@westernbotanicalmedicine.com,
so until the same third Friday of May, from 7 to 8, we'll see you
next month. Thank you.
[Music]
Herbal Med RX creates organic herbal products including bath and
body oils, salves, deodorants, herbal teas, CBD products,
essential oil blends, and more. Visit www.herbalmedrx.com to see
all products and events. You can reach Sue Lukasha at Herbal Med
RX by phone at 209-296-2120. Get ready, Shaka and Shyla are here,
so you can step out on a wing and a prayer.
[Music]